I have to ask you can just Oh  frightening incident what was your  reaction yeah well I found out yesterday  and immediately you know call Chris and  I mean of course they're shaken I that  is that's just horrible horrible I mean  to be kidnapped and tied up and gagged  and I mean that is just awful um so I  mean you wouldn't wish that on your  worst enemy and I mean I just hope that  they're able to recover and I know Kim I  mean that's that's gonna scar you for  life so I just hope that they you know  have someone to talk to and I mean  that's just scary I would never wish  that upon anyone I'm sure chris is has  her mom had on yeah I mean she went to  mom mode big time oh thank god they were  all together in France but um yeah I  mean that's just some scary scary stuff  very scary